This week PM Rishi Sunak
said his ‘working assumption’ was that we would have a general election
here in the UK in the second half of this year -
so potentially the autumn.
Who do you want to be running the country for the next few years?
To have your say
you need to vote
and to vote in the UK general election
you have to be 18 or over
and you have to REGISTER to vote before you can actually vote.
So how do you register?
well you need your National Insurance number
which will likely have been sent to you in the post when you turned 16 -
the letter that says
‘keep this number in a safe place
do not destroy this letter.’
Now if you don't have one
you can still register.
To register to vote
search up gov.uk
register to vote
You’ll be asked basic stuff like where you live
your nationality
your date of birth
- the whole thing takes less than three minutes.
After you've registered
your name and address will appear on the electoral register
and that means you are then eligible to vote in the UK general election.
Do share this TikTok with all the 18 yr olds you know
and look out for more posts from me over the coming months
on where you will actually go to vote on the day
and what you need to take with you.
This is me voting with Gracie
my dog back in the general election 2019
(you don't HAVE to take your dog with you by the way)